There are many approaches to software design.
Some espouse a particular point of view as to how best to structure a system,
such as object orientated design. Some of them are intended for
a particular class of application. That is the design of real time systems. And
some of them are structured to deal with only a part of an application,
such as user interface design. All approaches to design however,
include three aspects that may be compared, the design method,
the design representation, and how that design is going to be validated.
Let's first look at design method. A method is a systematic series of steps by
which you undertake to do your design and solve your problem. Typically,
a design method suggests a particular way of viewing the problem. With object
oriented design, we view the problem in terms of a set of cooperating objects.
Only later do we assign the services or functions that each of
those objects are going to be able to provide to the system. Other methods that
we may be mentioning during the course of the term include structure design, and
role based design. The design method that is chosen acts as the discipline for
the participants, the designers and ultimately the implementers,
forcing them how to organize their thoughts and and activities in certain ways.